hey everybody welcome back to typography
Tuesdays it's nice to see you I don't
know if you could appreciate the
lighting that's happening here my
lighting on today well you guys this is
a week this is week six week week six
for all you type participants I'm glad
you're coming along with us for the ride
and as we critique your type a lot of
submissions today a lot of really
interesting really good work as well I'm
surprised a lot of things that we didn't
explore in probably some ways that we
didn't understand how to use rules and
shapes so that's what we're gonna do
we're going to dive deep into the skra
TKE get prepared is gonna be probably
about two hours if we can help ourselves
around two hours so buckle up fasten in
now as always no kabuki amis here with
me and those you guys that don't know
her here she is here's our lovely face
hide Milka how are you thank you for
having me thank you thank you very much
and we appreciate you being here to
impart your wisdom and your design
aesthetic and your your wonderful lovely
energy now many of you guys who are just
maybe perhaps joining us today might not
know who Milkha is Milkha not only has a
master's than designed from Arts Center
she's taught typography for over 15
years which is a lot longer than I've
been teaching it so her insights are
incredible and just her energy like I
said before but Milkha's just not a like
a teacher full-time she's a professional
designer and she's worked at many places
including snap oh snap
no good would you do that snap oh snap
so the snap I was part of snap from its
infancy or it's a grassroots startup and
I had the opportunity to work with the
CEO Evan Spiegel closely in partnering
out doing a lot of corporate strategic
initiatives and generating a lot of
Purpose Driven brand design campaign one
of the projects that I'm very very proud
of is designing that logo snapping which
is a parent company for snapchat
spectacles bitmoji and we designed this
before the company went public
worth being worth twenty billion dollars
whoa worked on some things and at one
point I think Evan was your student
right
I know teaching pays off see friends
it's good to have Chris and I ask your
teachers you never know if you guys
enjoyed the way that Milkha's teaching
she's also available for corporate
training and other things how do people
get in touch with you and find out more
about what it is that you do oh thanks
for asking
I'm just connect first first and
foremost say thanks to everyone who's
been reaching out to me and my apology
if I haven't responded back yet people
have been emailing me they've been
reaching out to me through LinkedIn
through Facebook Milka design milker
Brooke InDesign my Instagram account and
I love being connected with everyone
Instagram account boy because I get to
see your work and it feel free to reach
out to me if I can help you with any
projects you have for personal training
or tutoring beautiful so I think without
further ado let's jump into today's
submissions there's a lot for us to go
over nOCA I just want to queue you up in
case you want to write on top of what
I'm doing some people had expressed like
hey mocha maybe you can draw on top and
we're gonna do that today and hopefully
we'll also have a few things that you
have taken notes on as well so you're
gonna see different perspectives and I
also want to warn you look typography
there are some rules but we break the
rules most of the time and where we
break the rules we get into some
subjective territory
I'm not saying Milko is always right and
I definitely know I'm not always right
but you guys see a disagreement and
that's totally okay because in those two
spaces between those two boundaries
maybe you'll find what you want or
you'll find another instructor or
another person a designer who's going to
give you their opinion and you might
gravitate towards that and that's the
beautiful thing about design many
different flavors for many different
folks so let's get into I'm gonna share
my screen now and where are you screen
there we are
go be illustrator
okay now in the comments I'll see things
like why are you using Adobe Illustrator
why why shouldn't you be using or
InDesign or quark or one of those page
layout programs there's a very simple
answer because I'm good with illustrator
and I'm terrible at those other programs
now Milka as you saw last week she got
into InDesign a little bit and there's
different things that you can do their
strengths and advantages and
disadvantages to the different programs
you use but use the program you got if
you have to use word use word haven't
helped you but you can use word you can
use Excel you can use whatever program
that you new have access to because
that's what it's about using the tools
and making the most of this situation so
we're gonna get into it now I'm gonna
start off with Bangor the Bangor is this
is that Kyle Daley submitted three
layouts like everybody else but his
layouts were so intriguing wildly
different I featured all three so I
think this is a good place to start so
here's Kyle's work okay let's take a
look at this so Milka you wanna okay so
I add cause I guess one of the last
pieces that I wanted to talk about but
let's do it should I share my screen
with you because I already have some so
I hit stop right now okay so let's see
okay so I can share my screen and I am
going to do that right now look over
here sure and I have somebody else's
work ready could we start with this one
actually we can do whatever you want I
was in a critique it but go ahead this
was the easy one and it's an easy and
quick one actually okay let me tell you
what's easy and quick when I saw this
I'm like good job okay so we've got you
know a big a big strong bar here and a
small strong bar here you know something
is missing here something very slightly
missing here and I went in there and I
finished with it
sorry folks if I'm not doing it live
with you but I'll be happy to do the
other ones live with you but I went as
finesse with it and here
I figured what if we put a square here
clean this area up and then the
typography I noticed they're different
sizes different ways and some of there
are upper case which you have to have a
reason if you gonna use upper case upper
case is important our practice is more
difficult to read so if you're going to
use upper case use it for something that
is very very special like maybe a word
or two but not for like more than five
words I recommend no more than five
words don't use this for don't use upper
case for that so I got rid of that I got
rid of the upper case and what did I do
oh I put the data over here so this went
over here and then I kind of cleaned
these up made them same I think same
weight which is the regular as this
series and I just moved things around a
little bit I brought this whole area
down so notice how your eye goes boom
boom boom I know that's your favorite
Chris says boom boom boom your eye goes
in and out there's more of a beautiful
flow coming in and out of this one so
thank you Chris for letting me use this
one can I talk about the other one too
please okay ah I know you chose this one
beautiful job beautiful really nice and
I don't know who did it and again it's
not about you and me it's about the work
so we can learn from it right so what I
really enjoyed about this is how the
more design was cut off we can still
read it why because the shape and the
form of lower case is so distinguishable
that we can we can tell what the letter
is
if you see the other half which is the
legs it's going to be more difficult to
see who is who it's like imagine you
have a series of people standing if you
see their faces you can tell who they
are but if you see their feet you're not
sure who's who so that's how it works
with typography so I thought to myself I
like what we did here what if we pushed
it and boom cut the top part off and
show them legs now if you're showing the
legs you have to be careful because you
can go so far down and to be able to
still see it because we because you know
this is you might first cook what is
what is that I'm not sure if that's a
bra but I think the if if once you
figure that's a T the juror the jury I
think is easy to read and then also
let's see what do I have in my lair
you put my lair over here oh let's see
okay so on my lair what did I do
I made this open because I wanted to
show you guys how far up and down we can
go so play with it so if this is where
it was before Chris by the way how do
you hide your your selections
what's the come is a command age come on
age okay come on DJ thank you oh it came
back it's coming back I don't know why I
have to hold on the command key if you
excuse me you come and play with it is
that good enough that might be good
enough what that space bothered me that
space right here bothered me so I came
down I can't die I can't die I said not
bad this is good this is good
so this is good enough to recognize that
this is a th e do I want to do I want to
push the edge of the envelope yes let's
see what happens so how far did I go I
think I went this far down so it's up to
you you decide which one you want to go
with does this help everyone yeah okay I
don't have my chat and open so I hope
this is helping all right good
should I continue or do you want to take
turn no no go ahead
okay moving on to the next one
show me the answers okay here we go
beautiful this one this one was very
exciting and he has this beautiful in
out in and out the whole entire layout
is active and I wanted to ask this
question I wanted to find out how else
can we push this for more don't forget
that when you're designing anything no
matter how satisfied you are with it you
can still push it you can still make it
better better maybe but I am not scared
of what's the word making it ugly I
think that's the key if you're not
afraid of making things ugly you'll be
surprised how you will discover new
things so what did I do
I came in yeah so let's have a line
party whoo-hoo all right you might say
wow this is so much but if you squint
your eyes I think we got more of a focal
point and more of a pool strength
happening here the other thing is how
did I decide what kind of lines I want
to have the way I decided the width of
the line is by going based on the width
of the stroke or the height of the
stroke like forces here I went based on
the height of the stroke of the leather
end here here let's see what the world's
where this is a good example
AHA yeah this may not be a good example
but I have it somewhere else where I
decide to go like the length that the
width of the thickness of the line will
be based on the stroke of the letter so
that's one way of deciding how thick
your letters should be any thoughts and
comments Chris yes you know as you're
working through this I think when you're
done I want to talk about how to use
rules and shapes a little bit more kind
of the ground rules so to speak how to
use lines and I like that you're you're
not wholly just wrecking the layout
which is often what I do which is I go
in there I tear it
part and do things so like you're making
small but significant modifications
thank you for mentioning that and I
wanted to honor the word because I
wanted to make sure what is it that they
have that I can't then we can push it a
little bit more yes and I like how Chris
deconstructs and reconstructs but I
rather make sure that the work is not
deconstructed yet but we're coming up
with solutions based on what you already
have can I shall I move on to the next
one
anybody has any question great progress
keep going okay I don't know why I can't
see my chat so folks if you're having
any and walk and chew gum at the same
time it's not possible just keep doing
your demo don't worry about their chat
all right so I just want to make sure
we're on part we're on the same page oh
we're seeing the answers all right let's
see this was a good one this was a good
one
and I wanted to take advantage of the
opportunity of playing the white reverse
tanks but before we go there two things
that's bothering are these elements this
destroying this rectangle and this
rectangle why because they are at the
edge of the page you might say okay
Milka it looks like as if there's more
going outside the page yes it's okay
it's fine I don't have a problem with it
but it's also boxing the page as well so
let's see I'm gonna turn off milk a
layer and then I'm gonna come over here
and what did I do is first and foremost
I took this triangle and I narrowed it
down so far so you can see that how the
letters are bleeding to the background I
haven't seen much of that with people's
work but I encourage you to try that
it's really cool and then let's not milk
us later on I guess it is on and then in
order to make everything clean and again
yes I kept the integrity of the piece I
came over here and put the line next to
the
for graphic design why because the power
of line is to bring attention to what
you're trying to say and if that is a
title and that is something that needs
to have a big power boom give it to it
and that's how you use lines and of
course we had to have this little
satellite so your eye goes in and out in
and comes you mean that I hope that's
helpful
I want to bring one more thing to the
attention here and that is I'm noticing
the whole entire typography here is all
uppercase again take advantage of
uppercase in certain places not
everywhere because it's difficult to
read uppercase than lowercase this is
helpful yes Chris I'm gonna pass this on
to you to pass the torch on to you
because I think people are gonna get
bored from you talking let's make this
more fun and have you do you want to add
anything to this Chris do you want to
draw on this I know you know I have the
files too so I could work on it are you
done with the ones that you wanted to
talk about or you still have a couple
more you want to talk about let's see I
have my own I have a good bunch at like
about half two three four five six
floating okay how about we do one or two
more and then we'll pass it back to me
and I'll talk about some some rules and
some guides to help people deal with
shapes because I can see people
struggling with it and and then we'll go
back to you to kind of yeah and forth
yeah here's your favorite oh wait don't
talk about that one
Oh No okay let me let me have a go at it
okay you go at it first and then we'll
come back okay go ahead and stop share
and I'll share my screen and I'll talk a
little bit okay okay I okay I'm going to
stop sharing my screen which is thank
you for having to control up I'm sharing
my screen now Thank You minister is that
it yeah good all you have to do so you
can see I've got a big art board today
so I want well I'm sorry sir sighs that
my father okay uh let's see do I go to
this
what just stop here please stop sharing
yeah I want you to share your somebody
stop me sharing now right Jonah yeah
yeah we could see your screen now okay
so I want to talk about this and I saw a
lot of designs and they felt very
decorative like when we have new tools
we forget that we're supposed to be
using these things to help the person
read what's going on on the screen
remember what we had over here the rules
where I'm a rules rules are right here I
mean we're in week six we're doing rules
and shapes basically lines and shapes
and we're we I just want to remind
everybody like the five things you want
to have a clear focal point you want to
make sure the order of the elements that
you have are the correct sequence you
want to create a little surprise in
there and the general rule of thumb has
been to create one trick one surprise
not like fifty-five surprises because
it's too much one theme one idea and
then let everything else serve that one
main idea we want to look at negative
space because the tendency is to crowd
every square inch of the page that you
have or square centimeter and we're
seeing that a lot now now that you can
add shapes that go beyond type people
are just filling in everything and then
we're right back to square one don't
forget the lessons we learned from week
one everybody and then we'll get the
details okay remember a focal point
order surprised and negative space and
then get your details right so when I
look at this and I say okay well what
are the rules of and the functions of
how you use lines and shapes well here
we go one you can use them to draw
emphasis I'll highlight this so you guys
can track with me to emphasize certain
things and you can see how I just
highlighted that that basically put it
the type reverse dot into a shape and
now that's where our eye goes because
that's a point of greatest contrast well
interestingly you can use rules and
shapes to group things together I'm
going to show you some examples or you
can use them to divide to say we're not
related
she's not with me I'm not what stupid
you know or he's an idiot like you we
separate things well we say no we're
part of a big happy family we can use
these same elements to push our eye away
from something or to pull our eye tour
something like it's all pointing at this
one thing or hey what about this thing
over here this is negative space and I
don't want to strategy with real
information but I think it needs a dot
it needs a dash or a line or something
and we can use it that way so now the
first thing I did here is I just took in
this issue this copy that everybody's
been working with this isn't America and
I believe this is like hair line it's
like really thin or no it's light okay
let me make sure yeah it's all how about
a canal light okay and so there's two
groups here and I told you before
proximity equals a relationship
they're closed okay but then that's too
close because they're not exactly the
same so we can use the line like this so
all I have to do is draw a line stroke
and say hey these two things a group by
virtue of having one element that
repeats the dimension of the box of text
that we have we can use lines like this
two horizontal lines with a thicker
stroke I think this let's see how thick
this line is I think this is like eight
point so two eight points and what I've
done here is I've done two different
things by repeating elements I say they
kind of belong together I do some of the
negative space but I Inc or these two
text box together and by doing this part
by stretching it out I make this
paragraph which is much shorter and with
much narrow and width in this and I give
them one unit of measure so I'm taking
two complex things and I'm making them
one unit and that way and here's a
variation to that theme here where I'm
taking that same line but I've just made
it shorter to kind of anchor I they're
these points of contrast right here tell
RI like look at this this is important
and when you're done looking at that
look at this and because it's a
repetition of the same element it groups
them together now this is where a line
is used to separate things so I have
these two things and I don't want you to
confuse them because this is who we're
featuring in this issue but these are
the two big things that we want to talk
about so I've added - or dotted line now
some of you guys may not know how to
create a dotted line so I'm gonna show
you really quickly there's not a bunch
of different pots here so if you select
this and you go into your strokes panel
you click on this and I'm going to make
the
stroke two points that's fine I'm gonna
change the caps to round because if I
don't
there'll be square lines or they'll be
straight okay so I want them to be
rounded and I'm going to click on this
option here to change it to dash line so
you make the dash zero points and then
whatever the gap is so if you want to
let more air travel between these two
elements all you have to do is change
the gap and I could do it to ten and
that's what it looks like now so at some
point it may create different feelings
the tighter the lines are together the
less it feels like these two things can
can be together and the more open they
are and it kind of allows them to kind
of connect through the negative space
between the dots did that make sense and
at some point too if you make these
lines too thick it takes on a whole
different characteristic
you see that now I've noticed that my
illustrator is really sluggish right now
because there's so many things on my
artboard it's a little bit out of
control so hopefully this whole thing
won't crash and here's another thing
that you can do right here we have I
broken the text now from two paragraphs
basically two groupings into one two
three four and sometimes okay and I will
say hey what about this white space down
here so I can take those two dashed
lines and just repeat it down here and
say look this whole thing is one big
group even though you can process it in
separate chunks all right and now I'm
gonna go into more lines and rules okay
so here I'm gonna take resonate the
title the publication the subtitle the
journal for graphic design in
january/february to show you how to use
lines to group and to separate how to
draw emphasis to things so the first
one's really easy all I'm gonna do is
take that text so I'm put on one line
across here I'm soo-min so you guys can
see this a little bit better and I've
just anchored everything on one
horizontal line which is this one this
allows me the freedom to put this text
over here so if I take this and I hide
it right now the base line right here
running across here is what connects
these two things and we can see that but
to make it even stronger all I have to
do is bring that line and now we don't
have to make the reader work as hard to
figure out the relationship between
these two things and I could do
variations on this now now I'll take
this on my highness once we review
something I'm gonna hide it I can repeat
the line and do one on the top and one
on the bottom I've changed it to be half
like this is four points and this is two
points in thickness and the reason why I
do that is I'm still obeying the law of
contrast where if you're gonna use a
different point size we suggest that you
double the point size or more so instead
of using thirty-six point type and
forty-two point type we would say you
use 36 and 72 point so if I use two
rules don't make one four point and one
three point seven points it doesn't make
any sense it'll look like a mistake so
it's half as thick as this line what
does this do it creates a strong focal
point at the top and it says hey there's
more down here so keep going down
alright alright so we've looked at that
I'm gonna hide that one
here's another example and the reason
why I showed you this is because as I
was scanning the different layouts I saw
like certain themes emerge and people
were designing in a very specific way
but they weren't using lines as tools to
aid in communication and to guide the
eye so I just want to show you some very
basic things to do with lines that are
functional not decorative and we can get
into decorative stuff as we progress
here okay so here the same line exists
but this time it's including a little
line going vertically and this is a
divider so the bottom line anchors these
two groups of information together but
this little vertical line says this is
the date and this is kind of cool
because over time this could change to
March April and now we know this is a
variable that will change but this is
constant this piece of information
constant this is variable so we're both
grouping and dividing here these are
such good lessons Chris and I might say
that some of you might be saying oh I
wish I had this lesson beforehand in
fact it's good that you're having it
afterwards why because you already got
your hands dirty with typography and now
you can appreciate this more so take
your work from this week and go back and
revise it and make it even better
you don't need Chris and I to make it
better you can do it better yourself
thank you for saying that okay yes
you're right I could have this lecture
but I want you to try in in in doing
things we've learned and then by
repeating those lessons over and over we
ate in the recall and the ability to be
able to use this in the future so if I
said this you may or may not have tried
it but I also don't want to
unnecessarily influence the designs that
you're trying okay let's look at this so
here we have basically two lines one two
ink or the two pieces information but
want to draw emphasis and they serve
different functions there and if you
take a look at that it kind of looks
modern it's kind of cool so you're
probably sitting there thinking okay
everything that we can do with lines of
shapes for these two pieces of
information is done but you would be
mistaken my friend because we're going
to keep going I'm gonna go over here so
here's another way to use now a shape
and and this was asked in typography
class when I was still a student at Art
Center
what's the difference between a rule and
a shape what a certain point a line
becomes so thick we stop reading it as a
line and we just call it a shape and
it's one of those things like like I'll
know it when I see it because at a
certain point you could say and you
could argue that's a shape and I
wouldn't be able to argue with you so
here this big black box draws our eye
towards resume the journal for graphic
design it gives it a lot of importance
because of the maximal amount of ink and
contrast that we're creating and this
tiny little bracket here says yeah but
we're related we know each other we came
to this party together yet very
organized and that's the beauty of it
it's kind of that Swiss modern kind of
organizational thing that I really enjoy
and like and so I hope to introduced you
to some of this visual language that you
can incorporate in your design work yeah
yeah very powerful okay so here's
another way I don't love this one but
there are three vertical lines
repetition remember it's all consonance
and dissonance repetition and contrast
and so these three things I know because
this is only one story hi and this is
two stories high well by doing as we
group these things together these same
principles apply to almost every kind of
design and the one that I could relate
to most is architectural you'll see that
there's a little window or doorway to
the right here but it's still enclosed
in this structure and it's pretty cool
okay I made this one dotted just to show
you doesn't have to be filled in as they
separate but our eye can travel through
the empty spaces here's another way of
using the line to tie information
together so in this case I made the date
align vertically centered and I put a
little dot there just through the stroke
right so if you go to the stroke panel
it's right there you can choose
different arrows and doodads and fingers
and all kinds of things but chose a
little circle so that gives it a little
visual weight and emphasis right keep
going behind this I'm gonna hide this
okay here here are two boxes that
overlap earlier on during I don't know
which week it was a week for something
like that week four or five I talked
about treating your typography like cuts
cut out pieces of paper
so in this case I'm treating this like
it's a piece of paper hmm has its own
shape it can block things it can
intersect with things it can be rotated
you can do lots of different things but
right now I just offset that a little
bit so they're grouped but separate
again lots of things you can do here and
we can get really crazy and I'll show
you what I mean
right now so I'm gonna take this and I'm
gonna type out eight let's just say okay
I'll hold my computer sluggish it's got
to think about everything so if I take
this and then I put it on top it creates
another feeling I wanted to show you
that to you and I put it behind it
creates a different feeling
it creates depth right so there's a lot
of things that you can do so if I line
that right there let's just say that was
a line and now the ease impossible to
read but
nice these are things that you guys can
play with and you should play with them
to figure out what works and what
doesn't work
same to same two boxes this time stacked
one on top of each other one in verse
and it crazy had another feeling and
generally speaking I didn't do this but
if you want to repeat the measurement
here it should be the same and then you
offset it and you're gonna see this a
lot in architecture for example imagine
if this were the first storey of the
building this is second storey of the
building and this is an empty space so
it's cantilevered over it if we're
looking at the elevation looking at a
building as if we're standing on the
street looking at it and you look at he
would say oh that's really cool and
modern all I did they were they took
shapes and they offset it and you can
see a lot of the modern buildings are
that are kind of skyscrapers they'll
take this and they'll offset it and
they'll rotate each floor a little bit
differently and that creates a deck a
roof deck or something like that it's
pretty cool if you look at some of the
work from Ginza you'll see things like
this same ideas being applied over and
over again all right Chris we should put
a class on that I like to sign up for it
what class might that be tell me the
title the architecture class
architecture / typography very cool
great yeah yeah believe it or not I've
actually designed buildings before
exteriors and interiors based on the
same principles that I'm sharing with
you today all right and I've had the
pleasure of working on many different
design projects not just two-dimensional
but three-dimensional one of my clients
actually hired us to design the facade
of a building and it was really cool to
be able to do that nice why I've said
many times before the secret the the
skeleton key to all of a design is
learning proportions and I don't know
how else to do it a better way to do it
and then to learn photography I've used
the same thing to design a floor plan
for my office to design furniture for my
my space and to design buildings for
clients facades ok it's not not a
structural engineering but yeah the last
one I wanted to show you here is an open
box so I just delete at the top of the
box and put it here and it kind of feels
like it's balanced on this little thing
alright so it creates a different
feeling and you can keep layering you
can do different things with this so if
I fill this box with
I'm gonna do that right now and I were
to take a shape and do something like
this and I'm gonna fill the shape with a
pattern let's say I want to fill it with
this kind of pattern and get rid of the
stroke and I'm sent it to the back there
in nineteen eighties yeah this is the
whole Memphis design style right okay
yeah April grimy era not April she might
call us later and say oh there you can
art so I I created as pattern which I'm
going to show you later let me feel it
sorry I didn't mean to do that I mean
here so like little registration marks
uh how awesome is that and then now
we're now we're cooking with gas as they
say and there's cool little things that
you can create little ding dots and
we're gonna get really experimental in a
little bit and I'm gonna show you how to
do that but I wanted to talk about lines
and rules I'm sorry rules and shapes not
lines and rules are the same thing
so here I've taken the mass at resonate
I've done the same thing I've anchored
it with a strong like Milkha would call
this the spine a strong baseline
something to anchor all these components
together and then I've cut it off so
we're seeing the head and not the feet I
love that analogy and then the journal
for graphic design tucked underneath it
separated about a couple things but also
with this little vertical stroke that
that creates a tee to say like we're
done there's no more information beyond
the stop here so or I doesn't have to
keep looking to the right it's a strong
stopping point and a way to kind of
finish the design so I hope you guys
enjoyed understanding and looking at a
couple of these lines maybe we'll all
point up to some questions to the people
who are live with us right now the 32
participants and whoever else is joining
us live via YouTube maybe you guys have
some questions then then we'll get back
into it
anybody have a question you know
other questions here we had a lot of
comments here but someone was really
saying that as an architect I could
totally relate to how great that analogy
was yes thank you very much because I
Drive by I look at these buildings like
that's wonderful and I'll I'll stop and
I have two boys
16 in the year old and a 14 year old on
I said hey you see this building you
guys like this let me tell you what's
really happening if you imagine taking
that and you move it over it they would
all be in alignment he's playing around
with these proportions I create very
variations on architecture and design ok
so that our live participants have
nothing that they want to ask or
anything they want to clarify on we just
put the question out there let's see
mm-hmm yeah we'll wait a couple minutes
okay well see I'm still sharing my
screen here so we can get into it so
Milko should we get back into with you
yeah go back to that first excuse me
clear my throat go back to the first one
please is that a good one yes it's like
the one that you wanted to talk about
okay so Kyle Daly yeah Kyle Daly this is
his work so he's got three layouts yeah
wow they're so weird and interesting
different and I won't explore this I'm
feeling like I was getting a lot from
this class because I just the
progression in the work it's been really
nice I agree and I really appreciate the
different ways he approached design in
this layer that goes to show that he's
really stretching his brain muscle
coming in from different perspectives so
awesome job Kyle I will go and share my
let's see okay so can I can I go share
now yes I I'm going to share mine well I
don't know after what Chris showed us
for I was having I was having a good
time with these design layouts and I was
thinking let's have it desert let's have
an align party and my solutions please
don't look at them as like being
something that has made it even better
but the solutions that I'm showing you
is to show you that how you can go in
there and take advantage of lines
further
to make it interesting so yeah let's see
so here we can I came over here and I
did add a lot of lines and let's see
some of the lines that I'm not sure
about these two actually but this was
interesting and it's not so it's not
responding there you go that's
interesting if you if you just ignore
the top part and the bottom part and
we're just we're just gonna lock that up
like that all and if you just zoom in
into this section that's kind of pretty
cool because what it what these lines do
is they're bringing emphasis to the name
of each designer they're also acting as
lines of text so I saw this opportunity
to bring these lines in here because the
lanes were there and I thought that
would be cool after looking at this I
knew that the top and the bottom was was
kind of imbalanced and then we had the 0
4 which made the layout asymmetrical
from symmetrical and I kind of struggled
with it but you can kind of tell I
struggled to see how we can bring the
whole page together
I'm not happy with it but I do think it
was a good opportunity to come and show
you how you can bring lines next to
names in in margins oh yeah I have no
noise let's see let's hide it let's go
this yeah this one was really cool very
very cool
but I was wondering if we have depth
with size bull and likeness why are we
taking advantage of the lines in the
same way well we could create depth with
big fat lines and
medium lines and they thanks leather
lines right so we're following the same
principle of large medium small and what
if we come here and and do bring that in
so I went ahead and created this big fat
line now how did I I'm trying to figure
out I think the height of the line is is
equivalent to the height of the stroke
and that's how I figure that and I'm
noticing this is not a good place I
don't I don't like where this is why do
things be the the height of the line is
the same height as the cap line of the
letter form all right so why am I not
able to I don't know why no interesting
I'm not able to manipulate it because
I'm not in that I don't know what's
going on but I see here's here's the
thing I didn't pay enough attention I
didn't pay enough attention you see how
this flew the guy sticking out I would
go ahead and cover it up even more so we
see a half thick line medium and thin
and super thin and then this was really
weird over here so I thought hey let's
have fun with it what if we do this what
if we do bring some black boxes just the
way Chris explained to us and have fun
with the name can you read it not at the
first read but at the second week it
does with a journal for graphic design
and again you gotta be careful who your
client is when your audience is and how
should you design for the right
appropriate try it in my experience if I
want to do something that is edgy I make
sure that I'm showing the client exactly
what they're asking for and I show them
a couple other variations and when I
show them the edgy edgy ones and you'd
be surprised how the climb I go wow I
like the edgy let's bring some of that
in
nice thank you guys should I continue
this yeah you don't need to ask you just
keep going okay because every time you
pause I think she's done and then I'm
gonna jump in but I don't want to cut
you up you just keep doing your thing
this was cool I put there was no lies
and so much time and effort has been
spent on this beautifully that I was
like oh no we went back to square one
like a rubber band we went back to where
we were
it's like it's like I'm sorry I don't
mean to give you tough love but you did
such a beautiful job with this layout
and then you're like I don't know where
to put the neck not you Chris but the
designer but they're thinking like where
am I gonna put the time ah there's some
dead space in let me boom-boom put it
over here
friends please be mindful of where your
text is gonna go make sure there's some
type of a relationship how do you find a
relationship like for instance here you
see there's a there's a relationship
here right there's a grid line here
there's a grid line here there's a grid
line here do you see that
so find these accesses to create grid
lines you also have these diagonal
accesses that you can come in and play
around with it okay this one just wanna
see no so I really wanted to see
everything in black and white so I can
make sure that we all know the principal
design so I went in there and made this
flag and I added some lines again I
don't care if it's gonna be really
really really bad because it's when we
do something really really bad we
discover serendipity and sin dippity is
one of your best friends you once NDP
because then you discover oh my god I
didn't know I could do that in fact with
this one this was serendipitous as I was
trying to put some box behind it it was
a beautiful send if it is where things
became edge and I'm like I'm gonna save
it and I'm gonna keep it okay so this is
let's see all right the correct me if
I'm wrong but this was a this was an
inspiration from Wolfgang right
weingartz correct me if I'm wrong right
yeah that's right
that's mine yes but good I'm so glad to
see that you guys are taking inspiration
from other leaders and other designers
that's good thing you tried it out it's
like it's like putting your foot inside
their shoe right when you tried their
design out now what I like to see is
what would you do to make it your own so
when we see it we don't go ah well can
weingartz by the way you want to hear
something very crazy Chris did you know
that our teacher Simon Johnson his
teacher was broken one guard that would
not surprise me so we are the grandchild
a wolf can Y guard and our students are
the grandchildren how crazy is that
sweet grandchildren and then yes
grandchildren okay so I to be honest
with you this was another tough one I I
saw this and I this one probably needs
to break itself into sections like for
instance where I would get my
inspiration is I would come over here
and then just just choose a different
color just for the sake of it I would
come over here and use this area as one
of my grids
okay that's one great so have use that
as a grid and then have your typography
within the height of that grid does that
make sense the other one would be maybe
where elsewhere else that seems to be
one good grid that I would probably come
over here and maybe repeat it repeat it
that's nice okay does that make sense
that this way you have some kind of
liquid
ever you feel like your work is not
talking to one another try to find some
kind of a common denominator
whether it's terms of direction with in
terms of height size direction as I as I
mentioned that find that and that's
going to help you to bring the whole
page together as a unit
does that help thank you this was it and
then the next one okay this was a cruel
one and as I was working on this last
I'm like oh man I should do this live in
front of everybody cuz I'm like somebody
stopped me I'm having it fun so much fun
adding lines in there so I'm gonna turn
off milk oh that's so I came over here
and I cleaned it up a little bit all
right
in fact this should be I came here and
cleaned it up a little bit I like how
the lines were hand-drawn I really liked
it I really did and I and I thought this
was a good layout good design and I was
thinking what else could we do to make
this more powerful so maybe we could
come in here go boom so it is up to you
this is more on the very subdued side
and this one is more on the powerful
side so if you're working with a client
that is all about power and strength why
not put those put those lines there and
notice how I'm using the lines the lines
like for instance here I decided that
the height of this line is going to be
the height of the cap height of the text
I decided that the width of this text is
going to be the height of the crossbar
of the letter T and I repeated that and
of course this is resonating with that
does this help everyone yes okay and
then here this one another cool
very cool this one super cool very cool
this would be a good one to do it by
hand I just go in there and cut cut cut
pace pace pace and I promise Chris that
I'll do cutting and pasting which is one
of my forte I love to get my hands dirty
with typography in a good way so maybe
next week for experimental Chris I
promise
psych and for the type the class is over
we got it get people excited every week
next week is gonna be the best I can't
wait for next week next week is gonna be
so good now sometimes we are so focused
on other elements that we forget about
the typography so we're using we're
using two different sizes and two
different weights I really want to see
everyone exercising their muscle using
all these different weights and sizes
because you can experiment and make
mistakes now this is a safe space for
everyone to make it to make mistakes and
with all the respects thousands and
thousands of people on YouTube are gonna
see it and they're gonna make comments
on it
just to scare ya all right that was a
joke but it's true
anyhow make mistakes because Chris and I
can catch you and what did I do
I had a ball I'm like who cares
thousands and thousands of people are
gonna see this and they're gonna make
comments I'm enjoying this and I just
went in there and I had a line party
definitely a party there yes yes because
if you don't have that in you if you
don't I didn't thank you then you're
designing with limitations and
hesitations again I encourage you to
design which a foot on the gas pedal
because when you design with the
hesitation it shows right yes uh all
right Chris I think that was it but then
you didn't want me to talk about this
one oops oh there's one more you can
have whatever you want okay so just so
you know I didn't go in there and choose
because I liked it or I didn't like it I
chose the ones that I was my computer
was able to read it with the font I
didn't have the font for all of them so
the ones I would turn into outline I was
able to work on them but unfortunately I
couldn't go in there and change the
typeface so it was a catch-22 this is
the beauty of working in InDesign and
InDesign you can include the type in
there as you package it but this is fine
I'm totally happy to work this way this
one was screenshot actually I cheated
here I wasn't sure all of it but I but I
went in there and I thought to myself
okay let's see what if we come here and
what do we see here I see this yin yang
yin yin yang I was like a Chris it was
during our time when we were teenagers
you would go play on it was before it
was right around the pac-man um car was
a pong yes I feel like a pawn here thank
you Mark I feel like I played a pot yes
and I'm like ah ha ha ha ha
ok well so what did I do
let's see all right before I show you
what did I did I went in there and maybe
I could I'm gonna head and see a few
things up and all right I made this I
went ahead and then I got rid of those
lines and I went ahead and made resonate
even stronger by adding a nice big size
of the line underneath it
do I like the whole leg together not
really but I'm just trying to put a
band-aid fixing parts of it
so this this is this is really exciting
how these lines are continuing with what
the text is saying this line is giving
strength to resonate
this line is bringing attention to what
the future and it feature is did I do
one more oh yeah I did one more so I
honestly I was living in my apartment
and let's see if I can come yeah some
lines that would be the nerdiest party
on the planet
yeah don't yes my lone party it's it's
you remember no because you might you
might have a client who my calm and say
hey I need something like this on you
like haha I have it I got it but but the
way I did these lines is all by
relationship it's just and I'm just
doing this live in front of you because
I want you to see how I was doing then I
thought this one was a good one to show
you and I'd let them speak to me I
really do
it's like this is not talking to me this
is saying ouch it hurts visually
speaking this is in and out mode again
with something here
anyway mmm like that yeah this is the
first time Chris is saying into my work
[Laughter]
we don't make the side effects it's just
that expressive I'm sorry that was a
happy accident
anyway I I can I can come over here and
you know see
again it's you can have a blast you
already did the design so come over here
and just just have fun with this where
else do I want to go maybe I want to go
over here and maybe now one day somebody
make a joke in the YouTube comments like
design the adidas logo you know I wish I
don't know who did it but anyhow okay
sorry
my computer is not responding to me
properly I don't know why I don't know
okay I get it so here we go
I see Oh No there you go uh-huh crap
click-and-drag there you go
all right let's see okay so while you
figure out your computer I want to
answer some questions that are popping
up on YouTube right now like well who is
Milka how do we see our work we're gonna
include Milkha's work or link to her
work inside the description you guys you
know we we actually do make an effort to
do this so a lot of people will ask
questions like just like that
all I have to tell you check the
description below no Cobra team is a
friend of mine she's an Art Center alum
masters master's degree so she's more
learned it than I am for sure she's been
teaching typography for over 15 years as
a professional practicing designer
former design Lee creative director at
Snap anyway okay thank you Chris for
that introduction and thank you everyone
for inquiring and I
I appreciate everyone's reach out and I
apologize if I haven't answered every
one but I intend to do so okay moving
forward this was a good one yay nice and
clean and it's begging for lies but then
at the same time I was like isn't this
the week where you do lie so where are
the lines
am I missing lines anywhere and so I'm
like okay let's go let's rebel so I drew
a line over the tanks is that okay is it
okay to draw a line over the tanks of
course it's okay you can why not you can
make such powerful statement with doing
so for instance I am trying to figure
out I think I was designing something
about sustainability and I came across a
design where they were talking about a
lot of things that are happening on our
planet Earth and they were drawing all
these black lines across it like no we
don't want to do that no we don't want
to do that and I was like wow there you
go there's a power of line to
communicate a powerful concept Chris
Ennio I did another one today yeah about
your critiques it's like you surprise
yourself it's like waiting for you Milka
oh so it was a question at you
is there another person that's doing
your design for you because it seems
that you got quite surprised yes
it's when you get when you're having fun
you get into the zone and that's so
awesome
so anyway I have to thank you all thank
you all for this opportunity honestly
and I'm doing this right now as we speak
if it's okay I'm like oh that needs a
line that is a line and you step back
and you look at it does it talk to me
something's missing there's something a
line is missing over there it's
basically a conversation between you and
the layout so you see how everything
feels very smuggled it's like if Moore
has a baby and Moore may relate to this
it's like hat it's like cradling your
baby with these lines and that's what
we're doing we're cradling it and
they're feeling good and snuggled I
think that's it okay okay you know I was
going to say something that I notice a
lot of students who graduate from Cal
arts get into really deconstructive or
deconstructed and expressive typography
and most of us that came from Arts
Center are are using type in more
functional ways and so there's no one
right way to do this and if you have
clients or work that warrant something
that's more expressive like what what
milk is doing then please do that and if
not let's get to functional type each
I'm going to spend a lot of time talking
about functional type yes mind if I take
over again so if you can stop your
screen share please yes absolutely thank
you again for this opportunity I really
enjoy them
all right back to the other started here
all right so Naoko always has these well
colorful expressions I just really
really enjoy cradling the baby and all
that kind of stuff okay so III do it
seems to disproportionality being spent
on Kyle's work and that's okay oh sorry
I do spend more time on it naturally
because I think there are things here
that we need to to look at examine and
to learn so forget that it's Kyle forget
it's Bob or Mary's work it doesn't
really matter whose work it is to
understand what's working well yes a
couple of things you know I'm gonna get
into this now Kyle's using the negative
space or that's sitting above the x
height of these words here and he's
putting his type in there I get that but
it's also kind of creating some unusual
organization and pairing I think it was
just for me personally for me it would
just work better if he just put them all
to the left and
right there and I would have just done
that okay so it's one thing I would have
done the other thing here is how are we
using lines there well not necessarily
use him to anger in the way that I just
previously shown you what I would
suggest is for Kyle who I know is live
right now with us or it was I don't know
if he still is but I would just try to
make them thicker see what happens okay
so if I go to the properties panel and
make him like let's try eight points and
and see how it feels like does this what
is going on here come on computer move
okay it's getting pretty heavy on my
computer right now so like does that
really draw our eye towards the bottom
if it's the bottom important is it not
important I don't know but I also know
that there's just too much black space I
have to lock this here
there's too much black space below here
and I don't think we need all that black
space so this could be like a nice way
to design a footer at the bottom of a
poster and I feel like there's a lot of
negative space on the top too which I'm
not sure that we need and it feels even
to me so if I draw a red box or
something like this let me feel this oh
I'm not used to mice computer like
clocking in like this okay I
accidentally created like some even
space here all right you can see more or
less it's kind of even and so what we do
is we kind of just play around with the
ratios and the proportion of the
negative space what if we took this and
moved it up north it doesn't have to be
even and then I wonder like why this is
also separating two lines so here's the
thing that is happening here we're
repeating the column width of these two
groups here this one and this one so
we're saying to the reader this is one
group which I need to make more visible
so you guys can see it and this is
another group but that's not the case
it's not the case I don't think so
really these two things should just be
joined together because this is
literally no group resonate the Journal
for graphic design mm excuse me and then
April May 2020 thats the other bit and
then we also have to pay attention to
how far away things are from the line
itself so we have a shape in here that
feels too big for the size of the text
that's above and below it so what I want
to do is move it closer because it
strengthens the relationship remember
proximity translates the relationship so
I want to move it down a little bit more
that's too much
maybe one day Apple will sponsor us and
send us a thirty thousand dollar Apple
computer so I can do this and it won't
be sluggish at all so there's still some
issues here and I think it's probably
just a thickness on the line but what
I'm gonna do is encourage Kyle to think
about using the lines as functional
unless it's decorative in his future
explorations okay a couple other things
that probably do is make these things
I'm not gonna do it now I can do it I
guess I'll make a little bit smaller to
give his design some room to breathe
it doesn't need to be that big and heavy
remember we want to let our eye float
let me do this we want our eye to float
around and explore like what's this all
about and then come back and do these
things and it's harder to do that when
everything's so big I don't think I've
improved the design here at all I think
I've broken it but I wanted to show you
or get you at least thinking about these
things the other thing is I don't think
this should be lined up with that
because there's no relationship there so
I'm gonna justify this right or flush
right some people don't like that term
justify right and we got to continue
working on it okay I'm not saying
there's a better design I think I made
it worse in some degrees but I want you
to start thinking about lines in
functional ways to group information to
separate things out and keep going down
that path I love this design I've seen
these things done before I'm not here to
critique you I'm like what it looks like
is that's the first thing that people do
it's like oh it reminds me of this and
they totally dismiss what you're doing
and what you're trying and everybody is
this way you mimic what other people do
to learn it and then it becomes a part
of your design vocabulary over time
through your own lens it mutates into
becoming part of your own personal style
well it Kyle's done here is he's created
extra elements so if I go to command
preview this you'll see that he's drawn
all the handles and the bounding boxes
to this and it creates another visual
element and this is kind of very
interesting because I suspect perhaps
when he was drawing this he did this and
he previewed it and he saw some things
like hey the gridlines are they're so
low why don't I make the gridlines
visible and so here he's doing it it's
pretty cool good job good job and this
works because it works because the
underlining elements work it under
did not work and they were not well
placed then we would have this problem I
do feel like there's it's a little even
between these peoples information like
this this space and this space here
feels a little bit too even for me and
so hopefully I will just you know won't
accidentally destroy this layout again
mmm good milk are you gonna say
something I was going to say that I like
how we're seeing the skeleton behind the
layout I'm very much enjoying it and
it's grouping it beautifully yeah
categorizing it beautiful block this so
I can hopefully start moving these
elements around curious this is a
psychological question I'm curious those
of us who are very very tidy and who are
very very very structured if they found
this assignment a little bit easier I'm
just curious
don't you don't don't feel no pressure
to respond but if you're one of those
people who really like things in a
certain way organize because that's what
line is line is to bring organization to
your structure I want to point out
something else here the use of circles
and he's using something doing something
very dynamic this is in the flavor of
Joseph pilla Brockman and I think he's
done a really good job he started out
with a really big circle here and if you
connect the center point of each circle
and you draw it to here which is in part
of the lecture and then you connect it
here you can see what's happening here
and if you use the golden ratio of 1.618
and you scale it down like that 0.618
you're gonna get something really cool
happening and I think that's that's
pretty cool he's doing too so good job
nice job nice job yay so beautiful to
see the growth yeah milk has already
talked about this I'm gonna make some
small changes I haven't done this before
so this may or may not work for us okay
these are milk Oh told me prior to us
coming on air a couple days ago that she
enjoys watching the design take place in
real time versus like the Easy Bake Oven
where you turn around and the pizzas
already made so that you guys can see
some of the design decisions and the
push and pull that's happening okay
my main critique of this is cows using
the lines to divide the space on the
page and
making shards fragments like it's broken
like if this were stained glass we know
this is what this would look like but I
think lines could be used for other
things and and not just purely
decorative for repeating elements we
already see on the page so one of the
things I want to try is to move this
here away so that things don't go all
the way off the edge I want to open up
some of the space and see how it feels
and you guys can tell me later if you
like it do you think it sucks so what's
happening here is just like typography I
don't want things bleeding off the edges
all the time sometimes I do sometimes I
don't because our eye is able to
complete the line and the movement
versus just chopping off the space and
closing down the space so just like tied
if I were to take this line and break it
so it's it's continuing on them we've
done this many times before we've done
this many times before up in in past
crits let me drink this water here it's
while you're taking a water I'm curious
to know how do we feel about this
triangle touching the edge of the paper
because to me that brings attention and
I'm remembering the design that I had
the revisions that I did I opened that
up I moved it around so it looks like
there's more happening to the outside of
the page so well for whatever reason I
lose my voice during these things and
funky things happen to my throat but
we're gonna persevere I hope you guys
can just bear with the gravel enos of my
voice here I think what Noah did which
was to take one of these lines and make
it thicker gave it a lot of visual
emphasis and it made it more interesting
so we want to vary the line weights just
like we vary the typeface weights it's
the same idea so I'm gonna go in here
and make this and generally speaking the
default setting is terrible and the one
point default setting of the line weight
is not good okay
so I don't love this part so I'm gonna
make this now a solid line
remove the - part of it and make it
maybe maybe make you just three points
and see what happens yeah since milk is
already worked on this I don't I don't
think I've made this a whole lot better
here I just wanted to show you guys that
don't be afraid to leave some space for
the design to work through the page so
don't cut off the whole page if you
don't have to can I give a Kudo to this
layout want one more Kudo is I really
like the scallion triangle and scale we
have we have three different types of
triangles we have equilateral triangle
where all the sides are equal and that's
a good symmetrical triangle and we have
isosceles well you have only two sides
that are equal and then we have the
scalene triangle where none of the sides
are equal and there's a scalene triangle
that's happening here and scaling is
exciting why because none of the sides
are equal to one another
they're all different you got that small
medium long length in there so take
advantage of that and maybe use that as
one of your perhaps as one of your grid
underlying grid for your design they act
I like that Nikko's taking us back to a
geometry class here yes it pays off to
high school geometry paid off pays off
to pay attention not okay I got a
related question here this one's from
Bertram you've been answering a lot of
this throughout this stream but he's
wondering how do you know when to use a
ruler or not and what problems do you
look for that rules and guides cannot
solve that type cannot I'll tell you yes
you're right we did answer that question
so number one rules were used to
organize information okay just like when
you go to Ikea you see a lot of
organization you see a lot of
help me add you guys you see a lot of
structures that are a lot of grid
structure you see a lot of grid
structure that you can go and buy things
to organize your your materials or
whatever you have so that's what house
how we're using lines here and how Chris
showed us earlier on with his
demonstration of how he organized the
information by bringing line to cradle
them so that's one way the other way
which is my way is by putting your foot
on the gas and saying look at me I am
here you know I've got power
pow-pow-pow that's another way of doing
it to design so think about it as if you
were to draw a line how do you use line
to organize information and how to go to
the other side we're using lines to
create more strength and power visually
now there was another question as from
YouTube and they said when we cut off
the are with this line here they happen
to read B and I'll show you something
here cuz it depends on where you cut
this thing I move this down here I'm
going to change this to B and you'll see
that the B looks quite different than
ours your familiarity with the letter
forms that allows you to read it as and
are because of the way the leg of the R
comes down and out as opposed to arcing
back you can see clearly now that once
is bez innate and the other one says
resume and of course if you cut this off
so high that you can't tell the
difference well then that's where the
problem is you see this this is a two
story letter form right so you have the
upper bowl in the lower bowl to be the
belly or whatever and you could see that
because it's curved here and this is not
curved here then that's the only thing
that you need to know but otherwise if
you cut it here for example you can't
tell so if we go past this point then
you should be able to tell right around
here and that's the pushing pool and you
can you saw earlier when Milko is
working she would do that and she would
kind of
she's making a lot of decisions that you
may not be cognizant of then she's
pushing things around okay the last
question I don't I don't know if I
improved his layout at all but I wanted
to try to just drive this point with you
guys that that you can use lines in ways
that dos don't just repeat the page
itself okay
and I don't like the proportions here
but eventually if I worked on it long
enough I think I get it to work okay
okay you want to say something I thought
maybe we could just zoom into it and
solve the problem that's all and the
other thing I did is I cheated a little
bit and I made resonate a little bit
bigger I saw that yes okay good
nice okay this one I want to talk about
this is from Joshua Gilley who's also
here with us live I thought this was
really bold and really cool he's using
bold italic I don't use a sans serif
italic or oblique typefaces very often
but here he's done it and he's done like
a really good job because my eye just
goes there it's got a lot of visual way
too and then everything else is like
quiet compared to that nicely done
mm-hmm I have one problem is that he's
repeating dizzy I just don't think you
need to and if I'm gonna go in here I'm
just going to delete it and I think it's
fine resonate now the problem here is
this good the corner end may need to
come out a little bit and and this gets
to the question I was asked on YouTube
like where do you cut things off so I
cut things off where like I feel like I
can read it and then I'm good and and
you don't need to feel the pressure to
fill every little space and and I think
that's okay the other thing is I don't
think we need this this is purely
decorative and it's not really doing a
lot for us from a design point of view I
think we just get rid of that and just
let this be the hero
okay Joshua again okay so you're using
shapes here and you don't have to use
shapes and every one of your layouts for
the the rules and shapes and you don't
have to use lines so I don't I don't
know maybe there's an issue here I don't
know we need all these little bits and
pieces it gets a little busy for me at
the bottom Naoko what do you think
I like the fact that he tried it out
good because you never know till you try
it out
that's one what bothers me is I want to
see the triangle the tight of the
triangle the top of the triangle I want
it to be less I want to see the letter Z
the terminal of the letter Z to blend
itself with the background okay you want
to mark it up Milkha now you know how to
do that ah okay let me go in there and
draw a parkas here so what you can do it
so what I'm saying is that let's see can
I draw a white box yeah I can I draw
draw yes okay okay okay I'm not getting
the box I'm just getting it large but I
draw the line for okay I found it I
found it I found it you guys it went
back to I guess see I am choosing a
format and it's giving me a line how do
I draw a box there I wanna start it box
by roof ah I can breathe now and then
come over here and maybe I don't know
but I'm gonna give it a try again
I let the piece speak to me I screamed
my yeah you still can't see the letter Z
okay it might be a little bit funky yeah
then you know we push input but the Z
can be still is recognizable I can't
move it huh all right that's all okay
cool so I think I'm gonna have to clear
this now and I could do this clear clear
all drawings there we go all right so
let's get back into it okay all right so
what Milko was saying that she wanted me
to drop this box this top edge and
could see it there all right deep in
here that was bugging her all right okay
you wanna say something no I'm laughing
how easily you interpret what I'm trying
to say well we can use a combination if
you drawing and you know or you speaking
and then and I'll do my best to help
everybody what you're talking about
yeah so I think the parts that you need
to work on Joshua are this area at the
bottom here and I think you could push
this up or down it doesn't matter but I
just want to clean up some of the stuff
and use the lines to communicate
something okay now I want to get into
this one this is from vishka I'm not
even tried to pronounce your last name
here because it's it's it's too hard for
me there's lots of problems with this
layout and you know in in the loving
nurturing spirit of look a good job I
want to give you kudos for trying busted
it's busting in so many different ways
like I think you want to pick a trick
and then stick to it and I think here
it's like we've got these overlapping
boxes and we on these white lines as
highlights we've got a lot of things
going on just let's just delete this
it's not helping you and then I started
looking at this and now we've got other
kinds of problems in here oh if i zoom
in I can see that these boxes are all
overlapping and weird rhythms and they
really should just be the same size I
think so the first thing I want to do is
try to get those things organized and
hopefully I can do it and then I'm gonna
go to a line here and just make sure
it's to each other to selection yep I
Center them up and it did nothing come
on
maybe it's grouped yeah something
Funky's going on there but I think
sometimes when you come up with a nice
idea and you want to play one around
with shapes and here we're using shapes
mostly as illustration and and and
mostly decorative then don't go and do
another thing this is the one rule thing
right so this is where we would take
typography like this I'll just steal
this one from that one right make this
white and you're gonna see I mean change
anything I haven't fixed anything I'll
just bring it to the foreground here
I'll just put it here make it Center
and it's just it's gonna be just a lot
better because we don't need so many
tricks
all right musica so let's go so the
advice for you is get your boxes all
lined up get some kind of rhythm like
they're all kind of
it's a strange spacing I think I'm quite
sure how you did the spacing on this but
usually when you see like really good
design see like right here you see how
this corner is cut off like there and
the these were almost touched this this
kind of goes and then this doesn't touch
it's kind of like all over the place man
let me fix this I may see why that was
command Y right yeah it just won't let
me grab anything there are your dirtier
lines became I'm more interesting so now
I think I can do it I'm gonna take oh
shoot it's group to a whole bunch of
things what is going on okay one let's
try something is grabbing that ah I
think it's actually grabbing this okay
now I can grab this and I'm going to try
to line it left here which it is now and
then get this thing lined up right on
that point oh okay there's still some
this is what I'm talking about the
details like if you're done with your
layout go in there and make it right
make it sing and it's not singing for me
right now okay Nia Morales Nia resin
where's the I so sometimes you have an
idea and your idea doesn't fit the
number of letters this is where you
probably want to add one more vertical
column so that this can work resonate or
you can do lots of different things here
you know you need to do this I'm gonna
show you a different way to tackle this
right so it's missing an eye there so I
like the rules that you create but then
you have to follow your own rules so the
R here is kind of coming in at a weird
pace for me it's killing me computer so
slow okay this week people sent me all
kinds of files and my computer behaved
in ways that's never behaved before so
it's a first like I couldn't even move
certain files because of the way that
they're constructed here's from my eye
you're moving hundred sixty miles an
hour so I don't know what you mean by
being slow I like I like 340 miles an
hour I just want to try something here
where you can use the vertical lines to
kind of create this grid this pattern so
we're talking about repetition and
contrast repetition and contrast the
cadence and and people have asked this
thing like how do you know when to add
the element of surprise when you design
become so predictable and boring and
everything is super gridded out you have
one element that breaks it now I think
that's a tear resonate he's probably too
big so I can scale it down a little bit
and maybe somewhere a design will take
place I don't know okay
but I just thought that you're missing
the eye there it was kind of funny
missing the focal point baby okay I just
want to say I liked how she's playing
with the reverse white line yes and it's
playful I'd like to see this layout and
maybe five different versions because it
has a lot of potentials to me I had this
beautiful dancing rhythm and I liked it
but it needs more massage mm-hmm-hmm the
other thing I might suggest trying here
is that when you do the resonate maybe
there are lowercase letters I'm not sure
because there's already this boxiness
that exists with the vertical white
stripes that you've added to this and
there's something that I want to show
you too so I'm going to delete this I
like how there's this uneven rhythm like
things go up and down but most of them
are up like they're aligned to the top
and only two are down so I'm gonna try
to do that where I'm gonna grab this and
this and I'm gonna move it down I'm
gonna try come on move down
and to create a nice up and down and up
and down so and dice too why is this and
Chris what do you think about the right
side we did have a box on the far right
right yeah I think we got rid of it yeah
I delete a one of them because generally
speaking I just don't want to take up
the entire page and cut it off so that's
that just there's just a trick that I
like to need to use but there's no rhyme
or reason to it just I find that that
works the best okay now now that I've
got that separated I can move this down
a little bit okay
and you know you can keep keep working
with this maybe this one's like really
down dynamic very dynamic right yeah
it's now you see type in motion okay so
some things to think about there Nia
good job and then I'm gonna move on to
Michael Lau Michael Lau has done
something interesting here he's really
taken this concept of the cutout paper
to heart and he's really done something
really interesting in my opinion so it
looks like the poor resonate has been
shredded to bits
and it's a really cool off setting that
he's done in repetition of the letters
almost as if he was thinking if I had an
exacto knife and had two versions of
resume I cut it apart reassemble them
together like he's putting together
something that's gone through a shredder
we get this idea and having all the type
reversed out in these boxes a little
nice I like that too it draws your eye
towards the shape and makes us really
aware of it it also has that kind of
highlighter or ransom note vibe to it
like somebody's putting something
together so I could see this treatment
working for a cool suspense thriller a
movie poster there's something really
cool about it I think the typography
isn't all working together for me right
now so we want to see if we can get it
to work so go ahead Milka thank you
Michael nice job and it looks like you
did this not by hand but on the computer
so I really appreciate you giving the
try oh yes Chris you read my mind right
now resonate is sitting in the middle of
the page if we take this page and fold
it in half you see that resident is
sitting in the middle we've talked about
things that are almost in the middle so
folks next time I see somebody doing
something like this in the middle I'm
not just kidding kick your butt I won't
talk to you we could probably take the
word resume move it a little bit down
use the law of thirds and then the other
thing I like to say oh nice job Chris
the other thing I'd like to say is Chris
may I please trouble you to take one two
three the third line of resonate if it's
separated is there any way we could
extend it to the right hold the shift
key and then extend it to the right
please yes that's the line that's it
perfect okay okay I don't know if we can
even take that whole entire layout ah
you almost did it though yeah so it
looks like it's because it's trailing
right so it can't be sitting so
perfectly on the page so it needs to be
a little bit less structured and more
haphazard there's some more randomness
to this more randomness I don't know why
I can't select certain things like
everybody builds their files and funky
ways this is kind of like why we
sometimes especially me will emphasize
good file hygiene it's math you will
call it because it without age just
becomes really difficult and you look
fighting this thing the whole time and
soon I blow a gasket and freak out and
we don't want to see that okay all right
okay so just having an element jut out
like that to kind of make it'll feel a
little bit more random those are the
kinds of details that you need to pay
attention to it probably needs something
up here but it's the idea okay good job
Michael this is from Jason Jacobsen
mm-hmm although I tap that in this is
really neat yeah this is like one of the
better examples of taking type and
moving in on an axis like this and then
creating the illusion of three deenis
and it's pretty cool very convincing on
fact here I'd love to see how you did it
how you constructed it yeah you think
about why mm-hmm so I think he's skewed
the type and unit like me an isometric
grid can you put a box around it yeah
really neat okay so this is a good
example of I got one trick I'm gonna
stick to my trick and I'm not gonna get
too crazy with everything else where
does it fall apart look at this little
cluster of information here we have all
upper case we have bold we have light or
regular and then we have some other one
and it's another point sighs too many
things in here too many things so let's
just go and make in this issue this
point size and not weight and just be
done with it it doesn't need to be
screaming Hey look at all this other
stuff I think by virtue and and and this
is one of those laws of contrast where
you have this big dynamic shape and you
have this little thing they really play
off each other well the only thing is we
need to have something up here and maybe
maybe that's all that we need tried to
leave this okay maybe maybe this is
either too low or too high I'm not quite
sure all right good job Jason yeah milk
already exploded this thing out had so
much fun with it with the textures and
everything and I think you just saw a
great example of that already I this is
where we use the lines to draw your eye
push and pull it's pulling all of our
attention towards the center converging
lines like this are always a trick that
photographers use to help draw your eye
into something storyboard artists will
do the same thing they'll take the lines
of a building and they'll draw with a
certain vantage point vanishing point
and everything will draw your eye
towards the center which if we kind of
allow our eye to connect it's right
around here somewhere which happens to
be exactly where resonate is so good job
on that I think like Milka did just go a
little more bananas on it and I think
your
you've done a great job Christensen okay
Keith Cox Keith this is one of those
layouts where I'm like okay we've
introduced shapes and lines but we've
fallen back a little bit we've taken a
couple steps forward we're falling back
here in my opinion Keith because it's so
there's so much stuff going on and I'm
not quite sure what any of these shapes
do for us in terms of reading hierarchy
or anything if we zoom out we zoom out
we say where's the greatest point of
contrast it's gonna probably be sorry
graphic design or this triangle but
there's nothing important in here and so
I'm not quite sure what's happening and
then we have these really awkward shapes
being created everywhere you've taken
the layout and you've broken it into
these tiny grids and in there like
here's another grid line up here which
has no information so this is probably
one where Milken's like Chris can we
just yeah I'm gonna just gonna bring it
up and at least just get rid of some of
the complexity it's not necessary go
ahead okay you're gonna say something I
think Keith is designing with passion
and I really admire that I saw his other
work and when I looked at I was like wow
but then I was like whoa the way I was
like yeah he is putting his foot on the
gas but then the war was like oh no yes
as you said Chris we're back to square
one all those things that we taught you
where did it go so Keith please go and
implement some of the things that we've
taught you about hierarchy about space
about contrast about first reads I can
read Vocaloid you know go massage it
this is this is a good design in terms
of putting your foot on the gas and
saying I don't care how bad it is
sorry bandana it's like I'm ready for
type war and I'm gonna go for the things
that are really funky because it's like
where does it my I go like where's it
supposed to go we talked about this
being a focal point right and it's not
supposed to be this might be important
but it's just
graphic design we know that it's graphic
design magazine it should be reserved
for resonate or something else this is
really the subhead and then it's
centered so it's kind of a strange
layout here maybe you're trying to
repeat the arrow shapes a lot I don't
know there's something this is one of
those things where you kind of start to
remove elements one at a time and you
start to say yourself is it better as it
worse find the culprit for it okay so a
lot of things work working they need to
be worked out here all right let's see
here I think you already talked about
Niki Robin yes
did you already talked about Luke Don no
okay
I think Luke Donna has also been doing
this all mark I think there's the the
grid ninis of like I'm Justin Mila
Brockman going on here we can see the
grid here so the question here for all
of us to think about is what is the
functionality or what's the function of
the boxes so it's easy to get mesmerized
by this stuff that these masters and
design have done and then now it's like
without the context of what it was made
for and what the boxes represent I can
just look at it purely on a formal level
like the shapes itself so we have this
thing to anchor this but it's not
necessary more emphasizing but then this
it goes here like overall like the
placement of the boxes of the shapes and
sizes are nice yeah but there's no
relationship between the lines and the
copy and that's what we need to work on
this okay so lift on good good try here
I'm glad that you're really having fun
with the shapes and placing them I think
you got a good sense for where things
are supposed to go but I'm gonna
encourage you for next week to have at
least 50% of your use of shapes and
lines is functional and the other 50% is
decorative if not maybe even heavier on
the functional side because once you
master the functional part making a
decorative that's the fun part it's easy
to do okay here's another one from lift
on I think this is a double layout here
okay this one's really reserved and he's
done something here it's really
interesting he's taken the traditional
cross access thing and he's broken in on
both AXI he's broken it on the vertical
axis
and then he's broken on the horizontal
axis or axis I don't know how to say the
plural okay can we have fun with this
one yeah what do you wanna do talk to me
this one is begging for like a thicker
lines like let me see if I can do it I
mean I can implement it oh it doesn't
let you do commands it okay there you go
sorry you guys this is gonna be very
crude because of the limited access I
have no foot of the gas go for it yeah
already look at that whoo that's talking
to me so let's see does it make sense
when I say let the layout talk to you
because honestly it does if you listen
to it you look at it and squint your
eyes and look back it tells you more or
less
I don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna be this
experimental does it should I go that
far should I go this far I'm speaking at
that I'm gonna try this far can I come
over here trying it at lunch like how
far do I go
maybe this this high okay that since
these have lines underneath them should
this one have a line folks I'm speaking
at that just so you know and then I'm
gonna come over here
you got yourself
[Laughter]
so thank you Chris and I'm gonna come
over here oh this is getting so ugly
that's good because sometimes it's so
ugly it's so ugly that it's beautiful
how do you know it's beautiful like I've
seen they're thinking back to you I
don't know but it is whisper what does
it say it's so bad that sometimes you go
you find some discoveries maybe not the
whole thing is speaking to each other
can I come and see that again okay not
bad not bad what do you think cuz you
want to add anything or subtract
anything I think I know one more yes
please sorry to interrupt you
I haven't said anything go ahead this is
what side Milken's had you guys okay
something like that I don't not sure
that see I suggest that we start a new
Netflix series called being milk a
broken consciousness we hear every
thought do you say I love Netflix III
hope Netflix will hire me okay so I'm
gonna go ahead and clear this there you
guys got this there's some interesting
shapes that are being gone on here it's
like clear clear all drawings we're back
alright
okay this is king when King has sent us
a couple of layouts so some interesting
things going on here excuse me alright
resonate so he's using dots here to
connect things I think but then he ends
it with this which oh I see it's up to
semicolon in the colon it's a colon
yeah it's the colon right so it's it's
kind of a weird connection I I
understand what he's doing here okay
it's usually like save for page number
like page 4 page 7 anything that would
work much better as a table of contents
to talk but what I really am drawn
towards this is resonate and kind of
using to point sizes and this is a more
one of the more successful use uses of
an a stroked type-a so usually I don't
like them but you have to use a big bold
one like this and it holds up well it's
an all capital one and then he put the
box around it too to kind of draw your
eye towards it there's some really
interesting fun things going on here
okay yeah dad I really like this layout
I agree and I like the fact that it's
trying to be simple gentle and strong at
the same time my question is that if I
were to hire this designer would he or
she be able to design different layout
in terms of using good typography why do
I say that because everything
at this moment is all cap our cap is
working in terms of form and shape but
not in terms of readability okay cool
can you change that the lowercase I see
a lot of AutoCAD or many of the designs
and yes usually it looks good it's like
having everything you know for staff for
center but then the readability is
hindered yeah so I want to make sure
before you guys graduate from this
course that you feel very comfortable
taking those body of copy and
implementing different weights bold
regular light different sizes large
medium small and multiply those three
factors which is nine right three times
three is nine you've got nine different
parameters that you have to work with be
aware of that and how can you create a
first read secondary and third read
right now the subhead Resnick is
beautiful gorgeous and I love how you're
playing with the lines it is creating
some boxes on the edge of the top left
it is but then that's the layout and
then everything else breathes - you're
right that's fine it's it's okay could
we do it any other way
yes you can and thank you Chris for
doing this as I'm talking this and I
wonder oh yeah I'm just playing while
you're talking please one thing Chris
someone said that you have all caps on
and the typography tool I do you're
tight cool type tool where's my type
tool all right all right okay I don't
see this here is that why thank you
change it no I
because he typed it in all caps so
sometimes she can't change it that way
well if you guys figure it out sometimes
I just I don't know why look here's the
difference between the two it's small
caps versus all caps see still caps it's
just small caps now it looks even better
because there's room to breathe and
faller
Chris I love how you're showing us the
difference you know you're comparing and
contrasting so we can really understand
and learn more thank you you're welcome
there's thing to uncheck both of them
okay let's try yeah okay you guys on the
internet you're so smart
boom my gosh so smart all right now I
can change it type a change case where
are you change case to sentence case or
title case I should I didn't do all
right change case you know sometimes you
do something a million times but then
when a thousand people watching you your
brain doesn't work anymore we didn't
notice that at all yeah so the other
thing here King is your you're going to
six point type so you're starting to
drift into some dangerous territory
about legibility here mm-hmm
that's the very lowest end where you can
put your type so I'm gonna let Milken
keep talking because yeah thank you for
talking about legibility in fact I
wanted to bring something to everyone's
attention I'm noticing that these past
couple of weeks the typography is nice
and tight
good job good job for being aware of
that be aware that as we increase the
size of the tie we're also increasing
the size of the spacing between so we're
very much aware of that however when the
text is reduced so is the space in
between so if you want your text to be
more reticle you need to increase the
tracking so if the text is small like
forces if you're going for six point the
way to make six point right up readable
is to try
get out so that I can understand and see
each letter and be able to put it
together let me give you an example
freeway signs we live in LA and I know
many of you guys don't but the freeway
sign in LA there's a lot of space
between each letters if you look at it
why because from far away those text is
not big they're small right so we as as
as a driver we have to be able to
recognize the letter form each
individually so we can read it together
so I hope that helps Wow Chris what did
you do
cuz I missed it it's just working with
the layout this time something that
looks funny about it
medium is a stretch or something I'm
gonna get rid of this extra spacing
something that looks funny to me I don't
know we're gonna keep working on this at
some other point but I just wanna take
this element that I thought was really
fun this outline version it's very thin
stroke and that's just duplicated
repeated it created this kind of weird
spiral graph repetition thing there's
lots of ways to create this kind of look
and effect and in here I'm using his
illustration but I've lost some
eligibility so I'm gonna show you like
well sometimes you do this and it works
and sometimes it doesn't
in this case I've lost some of
legibility and so I can counteract that
by just repeating then in the eighth
back so on this I make a little bit
bolder so we don't lose it shoot
computer come on can you make the top
layer app outline bolder make the line
thicker so maybe that way it stands out
so we're not repeating information
oh here you wanna be half of course yes
please mmm like it ghost coming alive
it's just an idea
mm-hmm I think when when I saw the Box I
thought about the periodic table of
elements and I was think
No maybe there's something there I don't
know
gosh this computer yeah I like it
come on all right whatever I like it
okay so and I don't think we have to
make everything fit inside a box there
still can be some really dynamic play
here and offsetting all the things we've
learned in the previous weeks you can
still play around with it and then the
rest of this I would probably treat
really simply and then be done with it
okay here's another one from from Kang
here again okay so using strips of paper
this one feels like those old demo you
know you remember how to like when
you're in junior high for you Malcolm
you yeah I'm a printer where you'd
select a letter and you hit and it would
print it out pull it off and it kind of
has that feeling to it is that what it
was called
daemul yeah there's a typeface called
daemul based on that I actually have it
I'll show you what it looks like okay
so why don't you look at this layout and
talk about it while I help everybody see
what the rest of this
okay sure all right I I think there's
there's a beauty about this page and the
beauty is simplicity but then can me
make this better
yes we can how are we gonna make this
better right now we're at a stage where
we can use different sizes different way
different lines and we talked also about
space from the very beginning there's a
lot of scatter space happening in this
layout that this layer is interesting
it's got this simplicity which I really
like but at the same time I'm wondering
if we go in there and massage some of
those space between those lines and vary
the size how would it come out I'm
curious and I'm wondering the other
factor is the margin look we have a
margin at the top that were margin on
the Left margin at the bottom but not at
the right so
that margin creates and so right on the
box
cool you found it yeah you could still
write on this forever
so yeah just talking about it you can
just use your red marker and just mark
it up so the name of the type is called
Dyne amor
this one's called dynamo I think they're
called time oh but I don't I think it's
a brand name and I can't remember but
it's something so yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what it's reminiscent of and has
a cool old-school vibe looking at
old-school back I would probably take
this layout and cut it up and then do it
by hand you'd be surprised at how much
more life will be injected into it nice
job Chris
Thanks so that's the typeface you guys
and you can real life obviously because
those Dino things can't be scaled but
once you create it you could scan it and
put it in a computer and I like that in
just me kind of rebuilding your layout
here King that maybe there's only a few
things that are reversed out and then
everything else is kind of like this the
journal for graphic design so I'm gonna
ask you next time to be very cognizant
of this I think most people when they're
they're starting out with design or
they're just getting your feet wet
they'll use all caps because all caps it
feels like easier for you because the
cap height and the baseline you get this
consistent line across and I'll show the
people with what I mean when I say that
okay so if I have a line right here
brush this out to five okay it's gonna
see this and it makes it easier for you
coach aha I feel a little bit more calm
I'm not as nervous about this okay so
you're talking you're seeing that right
but what you don't realize what milk is
saying very hard to read super hard to
read so part of the designer and you
suck oh it's just more even I feel
better about it but you didn't you put
the work on the poor person who has to
read it
so now we can see we have and we've
talked about this in week 1 yeah ooh
nice I love them spaced out beautiful we
talked about this in week 1 where people
really read the shape before they
actually can see the actual letters it's
kind of strange how that works so I know
this is Messier for you visually but in
terms of us being able to read it you
just have to get comfortable with yeah
it's gonna be better okay so for you
next week let's not use all caps anymore
use it sparingly we know that on
internet if you're commenting on
something you don't use all caps because
all caps sounds like you're screaming
and it's kind of similar use it very
sparingly okay but overall really love
the exploration just the range from one
to the next has been really good you and
a couple of people are doing that so
awesome job Bertram I think we've
already talked about Lars
also already talked about I think Milkha
did a really good job but just helping
push the design a little bit what I want
to just bring it in yeah nice because
you're cutting off all the space you're
taking one big beautiful modern spacious
layout and you're cutting it up into
three chunks all right tiny little
adjustment this part is problematic for
me why it's up here okay yeah I'm
laughing because I like what you're
doing so it should be something like
that
okay and then the spacing you have to
work this out optically to make that or
maybe it's on the grid oh no okay right
Butler Brian Butler had two really
interesting layouts okay so here we're
not using lines necessarily for
functional reasons we're using as a
graphic element and I think it's okay
because otherwise what's happening here
on the point out see this the spine of
the the vertical stroke of the e there's
some kind of grid line there and he
otherwise is not really reinforced
except for with this so what he's done
smartly is to reinforce it with this
line here and then this line down here
so really creates a nice access to play
off of
and it's really successful in that way
and again with
this year I think he's trying to tie the
eight maybe to pull our eye from this
side of the page all the way to this
side of the page and I think it's
working really well change with this
well done it's a little bit in the
middle of the page that's the only thing
don't move it somewhere yes where do we
move it I would like to see it move up
possibly please one more keep going okay
and then maybe we can grab something
from either let's see where it says
graphic yes that area exactly you read
my mind wow you're good
I'm just waiting for you to finish the
sentence you want to move this down here
yes please uh-huh nice there you go and
that may be that one too or not you
never know till you try it you never
know yeah yeah so you guys get the idea
we've we've we've gone over these things
before play with it and let it speak to
you right now the space between I like
where this school with the box that
Chris just moved is I will probably move
it a little bit more to the edge of the
paper possibly because a heart nice Oh
beautiful
and yeah Chris what do you think yeah
right that's it one click you solve the
problem oh hey Brian this is also very
interesting to me I'm scared to hit
preview okay but I love that there's
this square grid and that you've used
the eight and you've repeated it and
they're interesting shapes this is not
easy to do because oftentimes when you
crop letterforms like this you get
really weird shards and for the most
part I think you've done a really good
job if I look in here this is what I'm
talking about like these weird things
that happen between here and here and
these little bit right there
so those those tend to get a little
problematic for me but you can resolve
that I like bigger shapes like this so
they're not like these tiny little
shards like the bottom one is good
like where it meets the top line is a
little funky so I think this one is
really just taking the eight and blowing
it out and repeating it it's kind of a
nice pattern that you've created I think
it's pretty cool
and then the rest of the type this is
the another really good example for me
of taking one trick letting it be the
hero the star and then everything else
is just nice and quiet sitting on the
grid light in its weight spaced out open
letting that's it
mm-hmm good job okay let's keep going
here
okay now we're heading into this and
we're kind of almost in the homestretch
here and we're a little over time so I'm
gonna try to keep this really fast all
right Priscilla you're using the lines
to repeat the shape III think it's
redundant if you want to repeat the
shape try to find a more expressive way
to do this this is one of those very
centered layouts and I'm gonna caution
you maybe I'm just some dirty old man
but there's a phallic shape here I just
want to warn you this is the reason why
generally speaking no kind I are gonna
discourage you from doing centered
layout because you almost have no
control over the letters or the weight
the shape belt okay let me just draw on
top of this so you guys know I'm talking
about nothing you know I'm talking about
yeah actually in order to do a
successful center shape it has to have
that in out in if you look at some old
books
that might help you with the cover to
see what it looks like yeah right now
we're seeing it
III see a rocket actually but this is
something else it looks a little phallic
to me I like a Priscilla I like the
design around the edge of the page but I
get the feeling that you were you you
were ambivalent you there were two
things that you were in love with you
were in love with the middle shape and
you were in love with the outer shape
and right now they're not speaking to
each other yet so Chris how would you
solve that I'm gonna try to do right now
and I agree with you sometimes we see
that you guys come up with parts that
you really love but they don't work well
together and that's problematic
okay so first I'm using
like this whoo okay second thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna do this you know
why so many tricks we don't need it I'm
gonna take that in this and then just
align it to the left okay and then if we
need this we should use this in a
functional way and maybe group these
things together like we talked about
take this thing down here and then take
this and repeat it down here it's a
container we're related we don't look
like we're friends but we are really
friends and then we have to work out the
rest at first I think she had it
vertical because the lines on the sides
are also vertical I don't mind the
verdict the vertical lines if you repeat
it but I also like the horizontal as
well
what vertical no these lines yes the
reason why this line was vertical before
if I undo all this wall because it was
connecting one group with the other
right but as soon as I removed the
centered nature of this layout it didn't
seem to make sense what you went just my
left like that seems awkward like it's
sticking out of there in no man's land
thank you thank you and creating that
space are beautiful you can breathe that
okay
so we'll keep working on this okay
Priscilla good job so this is Andre
Armin's work and Andre is like he's
referencing shale a me and I'm not
familiar with this person's work but I'm
glad he included here because I think
it's wonderful to be able to study and
actually trace over and copy what other
people are doing I is this America
it's like condensed or something so I
just want to look I'm scared to like
look at it cuz I don't know what's going
on so it's very illustrative it's got
some is this article these lines
it's article right some Art Deco vibes
here mocha thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay and then and there's some shapes in
here so it's very illustrative I think
this is usually like what happens when
people get started with using shapes and
lines they start drawing and don't
forget that there's typography and I do
want to point something out before the
end of the show
here when you guys are using just shapes
like Pierre rectangle and - and lines
your instincts tell you what to do the
weird thing is when you convert the
shape back into type you forget about
those relationships or vice versa it's
really interesting because you know you
see there's a shape here this triangle
and then andre drew this line because he
saw that there spine here and he likes
the the solid nature of the shape versus
the thinness of the stroke and it's
really nice think about how your
typography works and I'm gonna show you
example so if we have a block of type
here we can take one line like this
rotate it and I'm going to show you the
visual equivalent to the shapes so some
of you guys who can think in shape
easier than you can't think and type
this is the visual equivalent to that
okay well you take a thin line and you
have a shape yeah almost the same so I'm
gonna make this bold so that I can
further emphasize that nice okay you
guys see what I'm talking about their
bold and light where is that thing so
the shape and a thin line
so if shapes works for you if shapes is
your jam if you're an illustrator and if
you just like making shapes think about
like what's the equivalent to typography
and make that work alright nice job love
the playfulness there's all the patterns
textures and tints that you're putting
out there that would be one of the great
like if I don't have the original
reference to references I don't know how
close this is to it or if you've learned
how to make it your own
okay faisal Omar this is a crazy layout
yeah and I like it yes it's not cut and
paste it can't wait for next week to see
well everyone how crazy there was a it's
gonna be no good this cannot be a half
Erica G you can it
no it ain't when loop is open yeah the
sound yeah but it has a very sexy s you
tell on my ass
now the s in the word design
let me take this line and try this thing
here so I'm gonna make this a lot bolder
or thicker properties D also has a
little bit of a spur the lowercase D
yeah yeah you guys can't fool us man
we're gonna see it so maybe this is one
of those ones where he doesn't have the
type to face so you know I like that
something like this taking oh [ __ ] I
pushed it too far there's like a 1
second delay for me so you guys when
you're using the lines use the line
still to group even though it's super
expressive and fun yes have a good time
this one go crazy and I like it that
it's crazy Chris I think we should
extend this class one more week so
everybody revise their designs with oli
their feedback and see how that goes
ok we shall see it will be extra extra
credit okay so here work from Stefan and
Stefan is just cut the page black big
shape I get it nice reversal everything
out it's definitely really interesting
here with the resonate not adding a new
element but cutting it so this feels
like a logo
lock up it's really nice beautiful
contrast between super thin and then
something bold and Stefan just mm really
good choice here very tastefully
designed I could see this being an ad
already boom so far I would recommend
you instead of having these odd shapes
of columns at the bottom try a straight
line instead this would be a layout
where you could go symmetrical you do
have you do have the option welcome come
on I'm sorry
tools to work with so what I'm
recommending instead of these being in
column maybe they can be straight line
all the way
across straight line all the way across
straight line all the way across so that
one's that straight why because you have
this at this center line right here and
then I would move that I would move that
and you know Center it okay that's all
okay cool so let me clear that boom
clear all it says so now that Milkha is
communicated to me what her intention
there is I'm gonna steal this line and
just show you so it's nice and clean
what the heck well that's locked for
some reason okay I'll figure it out okay
so she's talking about making this one
line of type yes yes yeah yes oh here's
something you don't even have to do what
Milko saying to achieve the exact same
idea of what she's saying so ami make
this point two five stroke and she's
saying like she likes a horizontal
grouping something like right what she's
talking about I'm gonna show you guys a
little tricky
no brilliant gee thanks thank you now if
I take the ruler tool which I haven't
done this in a while it's right here
and if I select these two things I'm
gonna measure the distance between this
point and this point and how far away is
that what the heck I not do this right
there we go
11.1 3-1 ok so just remember that 11.1
31 so you take these two columns of text
and you change the letting its 11.3 1
you should line up beautifully you see
that little trick a Rooney in here for
you guys
damn yeah and then this way you can come
and design my house for me some
suggestion there for using lines to
group now those things are grouped
together but they're also kind of
creating an extra visual element
something for you to think about stuff
on I like the original
I love Milkha's suggestion here and of
course I broke it here but I'm not gonna
spend the time to fix that but you guys
get the idea
very nicely done this is from Kevin
Portillo so I think I know what happened
here I somehow accidentally forgot and
left this sucker on top which I don't
want to do so let me lock that select
these things and bring them down to the
design layer and then walking back up
alright so Kevin is drawing the grid I
like that you like that so there's this
thing that muscle McNally is famous for
saying the grids are like underwear it's
meant for support but not meant to be
seen you're literally making it seen
it's like so it adds another visual
element I would love for you to start
looking at how to use lines as ways of
communication tools to anchor and lock
things up and guide the eye I think
you're doing similar things to what we
talked about before which is to use this
to group this here's the thing I always
have a problem with this I always wonder
why why is this box so wide when the
elements that are it's containing the
widest element is here so I'll show you
what I mean so we took this line you can
see I'm fighting your layout here dude
some people still don't want to listen
to me still want to put things in boxes
when they don't need to me
so then I you know I'm thinking about
starting a new show it's called grumpy
old man and I just yell at people like
you darn kids putting boxes around
single lines of type you already have to
kiss I'm gonna loving nurturing parent
if we talk about yeah okay so I take
this I think when we oh yeah I locked it
only take so Kevin I give up on your
design we'll just move on that's the way
I'm gonna punish you all right yo Chanel
yo Chanel okay some interesting layout
stuff going in there yes right yes
raishin yeah there's some really cool
reversed out things and and III think
this is an interesting wild element I
would not may put that in but I was like
wow that's kind of weird weird it got
interesting it's making it 3d in a
turnkey fashion it's so weird it's using
low-tech to create high-tech yeah so
maybe one thing that we we might try is
just to take this line here why is this
selected okay all right I'm trying to
take this line here just move it up
maybe I I don't know why I just feel
like one thing should be a little bit
weird so it's not all in perfect white
boxes but that's just me overall really
interesting design the problem I may
have to is here again guys try try to
not use these tints until you figure out
your design and you know how to make
stuff for Chris I think if I may defend
him oh yeah is that they're showing that
this is for January and February not the
other months mm-hmm so they're adding
extra information in there yeah so
sometimes I will applaud you to go ahead
and put in extra information with
genuine February or things that we know
that March and April come after
so we need to track that I would just
prefer you just put lines there and I'm
gonna do it just because I can
and since Milkha's not driving she can't
do it like to me this would be just fine
yes you don't need that and then maybe
it's just white yes and then if people
ask you why you have those lines there
you can say it's because to indicate the
rest of the month of the year and they'd
be like oh wow that's so smart okay you
know how did I miss this one well see
see what happens when all open my PDF to
be twelve hours before I'm as soon as I
get him done okay so resonate there was
a little problem there with a gap we
want to make sure it's sitting on there
another really wild layout yes really
like it it's so off kilter yes circles
like I personally would have figured out
to put that in then you put in on but
yes it needed a kind of a circular
element otherwise is getting to
geometric into boxy to rectilinear and
that curved linear element in there just
nice very nice okay well done Janek
urate okay here we have okay focus give
me a new I'm giving you a little concern
myself but go ahead and okay what do I
say well I love everything about the
layout URI except resonate okay let me
fix it yes because right now as as Chris
has always been saying you want to have
one trick you already have the whole
layout as a tree oh oh yes get rid of it
please Wow look at that gorgeous space
that looks like it that looks like a
actually a floor plan of a living room
Chris where would you put the resident I
would probably put resonate small and
dark yeah I'll show you where
I will put it here I will put resonate
very bold and dark right here got it shy
get rid of it no no leave it there I'm
fine we're working together because
right now the beauty of this layout
it's not about read resonate first it's
a bad read saw Lester Joseph the artist
first I loved it and then how that I
just rotates plans Oh beautiful
okay so Yuri I think you in the past if
I remember correctly you're very good at
doing this kind of clean modern design
you know how to tie elements together I
think this week I looked at a bunch of
your layouts are the ones that you
submitted and it felt like you were
still thinking how to use rules and
shapes right and and I think right now
and I want to sound like a broken record
but it's kind of design elements and I I
want you to see if you can use it in a
more functional way okay but it I think
the biggest offender was that repeating
our resonate thing with the lines
underneath it
okay let's keep moving there move on
really interesting layout really big
eight that's cropped off and using two
boxes keep it really simple
perhaps Milka will say they're not
talking to each other perhaps there are
three different islands the eight is I
would either go with ultra-thin for the
eight do we have that Chris can you do
ultra-thin for the eight yes I can't yay
awesome ultra-thin are beautiful I don't
know it's it's it's it's it's why do you
want to go thin here I'm curious this is
art because it's already really really
large it doesn't have to be bold oh okay
yeah that's possible can we make can we
make the outline thin oh can we making
an outline look anything you want
you never know till you try it there it
is okay
[Music]
okay okay it's beginning to have some
depth good good
it's beginning to have some depth now
eight is there it does have its own
space but what's important is about this
area and this speaks first second and
third I like the depth better this way
it is a little bit naked but Chris how
would you what else would you suggest I
don't know I liked it a little bit
heavier right here generally speaking
unless it's a really big go ahead if you
want to show me what you were thinking I
have issues here like what so this is
one where you just want to make it clean
you want to make it simple you don't
want to like be bleeding things off and
I think there's something going on I
don't understand I'm not even sure it's
this Helvetica and there's more text
going out of the page yeah it's just
like you don't need it just keep it
simple okay I don't we don't have to sit
here and dissect every single one this
is one from mozu somos done one layout
here which i think is really beautiful
yes that's a movement it's got some
weird stuff happening your mouth a
little kind of you have to be mindful
these little trap spaces in here but
it's got some vertical horizontal he's
got the lines here the rules to kind of
group these things together to say like
we're related but we want to push your
eye over to these two columns of
information and then he's cut this cut
this aid apart repeating his column sum
so some of its decorative I don't mind
it and then he's got this strong block
here to kind of pull your eye over there
yeah a little detail bits I like it I
like I do more good job it's a very
active page may I try something please
I'm curious to know what would happen if
we were to Chris you might do it faster
I'm just curious to know oh no I don't
want it like okay I want it oh wow what
did that come from
yeah let me let me clear clear my
drawings and I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna choose white text and I
want to make sure it's a box and I'm
gonna come over here and draw a white
box just to see what happens whoo look
at that now that is called being sexy
it's beautiful it's clean because there
was too much happening oh I see what
you're saying too much happening do me a
favor and clear that and I'll take care
of it
yes please I will here you go okay so
really what
Naoko is just talking about is you have
some really beautiful stuff already so
we can just get rid of some of it it'll
be fine
it is a really beautiful layout so nice
oh my I would pay for that design form
oh I think this is one of those ones
where I had all kinds of problems with
this file copying pacing at different
typefaces I think there's one of those
Memphis designs again I think I'm saying
it right to Memphis a style so I applaud
you for the effort the energy trying
this I would have never tried this
personally so it's like it's you're
really pushing it I see that you're
getting more and more confident each
time everything back adding graphic drop
shadows I like this it's tasteful it's
interesting he's even made a little
stamp here of course I had to convert
everything most so next time please do
me a favor and convert your things to
outlines just give me the option because
it took me a while just to get this
layout to look the way it does by
converting all your typefaces okay so it
probably a to inadvertently change some
things because of a typeface shift it I
can't edit it it's just a it's just an
image that I imported
okay and more at make sure you put those
two design in your portfolio because it
really shows how to diversify you can
design things yeah okay so we've seen
these kinds of layouts something must
have happened here I may have brokenness
I don't know so I'm gonna leave this you
just it's missing the lines and the
shapes but overall it's the right idea
just keep working out okay okay this one
I want to talk about this is from
Patrick right Patrick
his the the the 8 hidden in here okay
I like this label concept and just like
tilting it I think something has moved
here because it probably should be cut
off here you guys get it I I feel okay
about this like if this were like a spot
varnish mm-hmm something like a really
cool print trick I think I'd be really
neat Yeah right it's just like one
little idea illustration I think it also
can work just fine with just like a full
eight that you drop in here without
having to repeat it making this texture
out of it but really well done jing
wang' and the reason why you guys I'm
rushing is we're 26 minutes over and
soon my son is gonna have piano lesson
or something like that so we're gonna
interrupt it Jing really nice layout I
like it
you're using all caps here making it
hard to read I know that the shapes are
easier for you but it's much harder to
read using these lines to draw I across
or reinforce the grid lines all very
good nice layout probably a couple
modifications here and there but overall
very successful nice job Christina nice
job Christina just Donna okay some cut
line here some angles very dynamic some
grid lines being pull apart again no
shapes no lines in this one really it's
a separator bar so I'd love for you to
keep going Christina sometimes I think
we get into a good groove and then we
kind of get stuck and we repeat the same
things I think Christina you've mastered
this style layout already I'm gonna
encourage you just keep going alright
this might add to what you just said
everyone these are I'm sorry to say this
to you but these are not masterpieces
okay don't treat them like they are you
gotta treat them like exercises they're
exercises to help you with your future
work so if you did this Christina I hope
which I know you already have this saved
make another copy and just go either and
attack it with lines and see what
happens it's gonna bring something like
for some reasons not rendering the same
way that she designed it so yeah I have
problems with some of your layouts you
guys I really do as soon as I open your
files is that's missing place files and
all kinds of things are happening here
so if you if you embed an illustrator
file inside your file you got to make
sure that it's packaged and saved in a
way that those things
transfer over as soon as I open up
everything's busted and I'm sure there's
something else that's going on here I
can't share screen real quick I have it
up okay we got time
not really but go ahead okay yeah oh
here we go
so she's modified it and she's got some
paper background cutouts that you can
see cool so there's a little overlay and
looks like there's a little background
mmm
Brisa like a 3d dimension too which is
pretty cool yes it does okay it's not
yeah okay
so Cristina and everybody says that
wants to submit something with images
embedded save the file in that way so I
can see it and it's probably one of the
reasons why my machine is choking right
now because everybody's got some crazy
stuff going on so another way to do that
is export it as a PDF or a JPEG so I can
see it and then I won't be able to edit
it but at least we can see your intent
that drastically changes the design some
really cool stuff that you're doing
there so kudos to you alright I'm
rushing here because the this is it we
have two left and then we're gonna
bounce okay everybody so June June okay
so something I can tell is already
shifted in my artboard some somehow I
accidentally move something here well
that's okay figure it out okay so she
split the layout two-thirds one-third I
get that the journal for graphic design
June is another person I think who was
really good at making structured
functional typography I think this week
she hasn't pushed the limits far enough
to kind of figure out how to use lines I
think the ones that are inserted in here
are mostly decorative to fill up the
negative space I don't love it and it's
because it's all very similar the
journal I guess I understand why you
chose that way to the same stroke as the
journal for graphic design but it's
really just breaking up the space and
even this lock up is just not handsome
son that's not good looking for me yes
Chris maybe no call so different I don't
know I I agree with you Chris it's a
flat piece it's flat
okay thanks why can't I select this
thing appointment myself - can you one
second here
I feel like June was a little bit
hesitant what to do with lies June not
that you you've seen this week's
exercises I'm curious to know what else
would you do house would you improve
this and I have good faith in you that
you're gonna really make this rock even
more yeah so hey June alright the
Jennifer graphic design like when I
delete the elements these lines it has
its problematic already in here right it
really is so when when you have that
problem when you just add more it's like
what we like to just pouring it's
putting lipstick on a pig what can I say
so I think the problem here is just in
the base type if you fix this part and
then you start to think about how can I
use the lines to connect ideas to divide
to draw emphasis then it will work so
this I already know the problem is in
this right here okay so fix that and
everything the layout starts to come
together okay sorry you guys if you were
to if I were to cheat here I would go
ahead and put a black box over the
thought of the eye because you can still
read the word design okay you just
delete that yeah to make it more
readable yeah okay Toni Gibbs Toni Gibbs
really interesting thing here Tony has
repeated the type a gazillion times guys
see features and it just keeps going on
and on and on where are the lines the
lines the lines so why are we talking
about it we talk about other things
about lines no Lithonia I think you've
done some something interesting here
you've created a big gigantic shape
through repetition let me do this
alright and you created a vertical shape
here
you created another one here so overall
good shapes good rhythm good flow and
even if I black it out actually looks
better so use the parameters of this
week to your advantage what do I mean by
that if you just took this type it
didn't need to repeat you just put in a
black box and you have the same exact
impact the same effect all right so
remember how I was saying to you to you
guys before that some of you guys are
really good at using type of shapes and
some of you guys are using really good
at using shapes but this is where you
push and pull you have an additional
element I want you to master how to use
this and to break it up I think honestly
some of this type could be a lot smaller
because a lot of points is a weird point
there I'll make it eight points maybe
decrease the lighting here next week I
can only imagine what you guys gonna do
and how my computer's gonna struggle to
keep up with you cuz this week it's
already choking next week is like
doomsday
okay so shapes and lines okay really
explore that I think those are all the
layouts that we pulled it now I have
something else there's a whiteboard here
for a reason
because because I want to talk about
what we can do now you remember last
week when I screen captured some of
these typography I don't know who it is
I started playing around with that and I
started introducing textures and shapes
and things like that so next week we're
going to go into the land of
experimentation and I want you to try to
break it I want you to make it and then
bring it back from ugly Ville and bring
it back into to making it something
that's cool that's structured that's
handsome looking and I want to be able
to do that what about this I mean it's a
storefront and and folks if I may add to
what just Chris's because when you're
doing experimental doesn't mean that
it's going to be a hodgepodge know the
rules of unity harmony balance hierarchy
scale proportion emphasis focal point
contrast they still apply so be aware of
that
but go for it go design let us let the
piece talk to you and then you can go in
there and massage it to bring emphasis
to bring focal point to
should pull it by adding more contrast
so I'm gonna show you a couple of little
things I'm gonna try here so I'm just
cutting up the type of course we're
missing some of the type and you can
argue we need it back in and eventually
I'll work it back in but I wanted to
show you some things okay so some people
don't know this but if you draw a shape
like this right shoot
grab the shape movie to the side here
and I'll just color it there's black and
white that's what we're allowed to work
with black and white but I don't know if
you go to ever go down to the window
swatch libraries I mean you go all the
way down to patterns there's a bunch of
things that already built into
illustrator decorative nature or
whatever so there's basic graphic dots
lines and textures I've already set up
my machine to do this so if I go over
here click on this folder here so I can
fill this with thoughts I can fill it
with all kinds of things really cool
things I can play these halftone dots
and different sizes and shapes and
things like that and then this gives me
even more option and varieties to work
with so now your heads gonna explode
okay so that's just one of those things
and you can go over here and you click
on this one this will give me some lines
horizontal lines vertical lines I love
it right so you guys can get in it and
there's another one here these are the
textures these are sometimes not so good
but they're there for you to try and
play all right so Chris we're gonna keep
this black and white only black and
white I can't ever change experimental I
want to show you a couple other tricks
as people are heading off into the
sunset and trying to figure this out
see this little registration mark here I
drew this right that's very easy to draw
well I wanted to repeat it all over the
place and this is where I'm talking
about file hygiene here if I want to
repeat this across the the easiest way
to do is this I'm just duplicated or
command D right and then what I would do
is then I would group this and then I do
to clear this way and I put in here and
I could manipulate it but then I have a
lot of elements on the screen let me
show you different way to do this if you
select this you go to object I think and
somewhere near is pattern and I'm gonna
make a pattern right making patterns
that never been easier to do in
Illustrator than it has
in the latest couple upgrades so I'm
gonna go make and so it's gonna ask me
this almost like don't show me is I
don't want to see this just okay so I'm
gonna I can see this here I can zoom in
so it's just focus on the pattern and
you can see right now this is the
default it sets it to great but you can
do brick by brick you can offset it
there's a lot of different things you
can do so a lot of fun ways to handle
this you see this right here it's
putting inside of a hexagon there and
then if I increase the spacing of the
width so if I go 250 under 50 don't
start to space it out you're cool
that's something's happening here I
could change to them or copy so 3 by 3
PI by 5 whatever it is just so I can see
how this looks okay and I want to leave
the dim I don't want dim the copies
that's fine
so once I hit okay we're done okay and
I'm done so if you go here you can save
a copy done or cancel right up here in
the top left right I'm gonna cancel
because I've already done it so all you
need to do is use it now so I'm gonna
draw a box just like I was doing before
why is it something happened yeah I did
it to me too
okay so I'm gonna draw a box now and I'm
going to select the pattern I've already
made and it's right at this one no right
there boom and I don't want to I don't
want to stroke around my box here so I'm
gonna take this stroke off and then now
you can get into it
this is all 2d type all built into Adobe
Illustrator things that you can play
around with and whatever program you're
using have fun and if I scale this down
it will also scale the pattern down so I
can get a smaller our pattern I think
yeah and the way that you make sure that
that's working the way that you want it
to is you go to command K and you sale
scale strokes and patterns and things
like that somewhere in there there's a
preference for you to do that I want to
show you a couple like last little
things here
I'm gonna import some files in here I
want to show you what else you can do
don't forget you have a printer you
probably have a scanner you can drop
InDesign so
I want to open it up your mind okay
coming down to end here you can print
something out you can scrunch it you
could kind of it up alright you can cut
it up and then you can scan it back in
and you can do something really cool
with that
and this is the preferred path to take
if you want to distort your type don't
try to do this all inside Photoshop I
know you can many of you guys know how
to do all these tricks so you can wave
it so I saw many many years ago 20 years
20 plus years ago when I was in our
Center in the computer lab I saw another
designer he would do all kinds of weird
tricks on top of the scanner he would
hold it in place and make it warp while
the scanner head was gaining it so it
created these weird undulating type that
was super fun and easy to do he would
space it off the glass with pennies he
would sack some pennies and space some
of it off the glass says the scanner
came by he made it out of focus and
added texture to things so I want you to
try and do stuff okay now if you're
gonna do some crazy files make sure
you're practicing good file hygiene
because if I can't open if I can't edit
it I'm moving on it's no reflection from
the quality redesign it's it's a
reflection on the quality of your file
because I don't want a computer to break
okay so if you got some crazy stuff go
ahead and export as a PDF outline all
your type and the last thing you do is
if you have a bunch of embedded images
maybe just export it as a clean JPEG and
I'll import and we can talk about it I
won't be able to edit it but that's okay
it's preferable than not showing it at
all okay I think that's it for me I'm
gonna stop this thing guys thanks for
hanging in there with us for all of you
guys that made it all the way in today
and congratulations now go ahead and
reward yourself by hitting subscribe in
the bail notification right now all 400
of you guys okay I appreciate you guys
in Milka as always thanks so much for
being my co-pilot currently there is no
plan for an 8th week 7 weeks we're done
I'm exhausted I have to make some money
I have to work on projects and write
things you know I got work to do you
guys you see how much time it takes for
them both of us and don't forget I'll
include all of Milkha's information in
the links below guys and let me know how
you feel about my new color and lighting
set up here this is my webcam it's a fan
always look good
matter what thank you okay I did I think
that's it on behalf of the entire team
Jonah mark myself and okay guys have a
great week and we'll see you next time
and next time anything goes
experiment away do as many as your heart
desires and then submit him I'm a blast
have a blast take care bye everyone
everybody goodbye